this year and that the with finding
fault with our foreign
capital gains
medical benefit of the way so we can
take your property is a peace deal
that's why the government
invented eminent
eminent domain is like cancer
well
but there's one thing they sell your
house for dinner table
the federal government does what you had
you're on the gun you're going to take
it or forget about it
always been a republican if never called
marijuana
was d criminalized nationally deviates
stood down products now
some freedom
happily god
portion of the for these cities
i would love the owner freeway in l_a_
my adverse he is
between nine
and sixteen miles
ready for the year uses for work every
day life
people don't ever doesn't crash
that's ridiculously
what's up
the entrance and exit
but reason that debate
carried have either your but not
drag